the streets of tunisia's capital are
mostly calm
but on wednesday the president again
moved to tighten his control of the
government
speaking in a televised interview
president kai syed
accused politicians of corruption
costing the country
billions of dollars the money stolen
from the tunisian people must be
restored
a decision will be made to take measures
against the perpetrators
who have taken these public funds we
will deal with these people in a
proportionate manner
that accusation is disputed by a nata
the largest party in the government
coalition
these are not new allegations uh these
have been
raised by rival parties many years ago
and repeatedly
tunisian law of parties is quite um
strict in terms of funding and uh
another has always complied
uh with with the law there has never
been any evidence of of such foreign
funding
young democracy faces its worst crisis
in a decade after the president ousted
the government and froze parliament for
30 days
[Applause]
the president says he has acted
constitutionally but opposition leaders
accuse him of staging a coup
one analyst says saeed's moves are
popular
at least for now the question now is not
whether this is a coup or not
today a recent poll has shown that 87
percent of tunisians
they agree with the decisions of kaisei
and 76 they totally agree with him
so as we can see here the decisions are
really very popular
are they feasible well let's wait and
see
further afield foreign leaders have been
calling for cabinet changes to be swift
the takeover comes amid crisis the
coronavirus pandemic is ravaging the
nation
and the economy is in steep decline
the international monetary fund recently
promised to help tunisia cope with its
growing financial pressure
the president has been calling on
traders to cut the cost of goods
but even that these local shop owners
say won't do
since the revolution life has become
very difficult the people can't make do
although we sell meat with low prices
this market is cheap
and even in this cheap market people
can't manage
and so residents wait to see whether the
streets which witnessed the jasmine
revolution a decade ago
will remain silent jillian wolf
al jazeera